the Joe Rogan experience it's
fascinating to me did you watch the game
of Thrones finale did you get bummed out
I got I you know what not somebody else
wrote I think they did yeah it's very
strange I thought they did
I love I did like season eight and I was
kids the other seasons hey Liss who's
[ __ ] get everybody know right now
spoiler alert hold up what is today
Thursday yeah yeah but some people it's
Sunday some people jobs sunny day people
work all day for days
some people were called to the New York
Times like put it on the front page of
the paper I'm unclear bro yeah but they
did that because they can do that not
because they should do that the next
day's little [ __ ] well I think I think I
think movies is you got a week movies
you got a week TV show two days damn
especially for that what are we not
supposed to talk about it cuz you're
busy
that's insane did you like you actor
what is no I didn't other satisfied I'd
left unsatisfied when they made spoil or
homeboy the King I was like what in the
[ __ ] are you talking about he didn't
want it the whole I can see the sudden
everybody's fighting to the death over
who's the king they're ready ready to
stab their brother kill their mom
they'll kill anybody they'll betray
lovers but now this guy's like alright
I'll take it now I think you should be
the king they're like okay like that was
great and how about that one guy that
just stood up and is like maybe I could
be the king they like sit down I said
citizens just Sopranos like what do you
what are you doing which means this guy
Bobby Lee had that guy Bobby Lee had the
greatest I thought it's such a good
ending so he says when everyone goes you
know when the decided to be the king and
then home boy who's crippled is like
I'll do it and then when they were
wheeling my way he just looks over and
he has the [ __ ] white Walker I that
would work and then it closes you know
what should happen that's Bobby Lee's
idea Jon Snow should have fought to the
death with that dude who has no dick
yeah I wouldn't see that she's good to
the death they hated each other they
hate each other how about that dude
psych
yeah just like killed my girl CEO big
deal just you get on the boat there's no
way they should have fought to the death
did you like episode 3 I'll tell you
what I like though like when the the one
that the Hound
knocked the mountain off of the fire
that was dope
now addict just a fire that was a dope
scene [ __ ] was dumb the best scene in
the whole [ __ ] series though was when
you know the beds best scene in the
whole [ __ ] series when when she was
telling that dude that he betrayed her
and then from the darkness the Dragons
face appears and you're like oh Jesus
this is where I was a powerful scene
those dragons are so [ __ ] scary
I'm so happy there's people out there
that do special effects like that that
[ __ ] was dope cause he used to be kind
of like samurai corny like super corny
remember what was that movie there was a
good dragon movie with Matthew
McConaughey back when Matthew
McConaughey was jacked up in the show
homeboy from Australia was in a - Batman
[ __ ] his name oh [ __ ] was his name
Christian berenstain bears two barrels
in a chicken fire what does it call rain
of fire yeah the dragons in there were
corny compared to the kings of Thrones
be believe me see let me see a video
that public obviously we can't show it
on the podcast or we'll get arrested and
castrated joe carnahan was just talking
about this bro this [ __ ] movie was
not a bad movie it was a little corny
but for a dummy like me who really likes
dragons it was great stuff it was an
interesting movie but the Dragons it's
just crazy how much because I want to
say this was probably 2004 I might
correct for that - 2 then 2 oz pretty
close yeah pretty close you've been on
but the difference between what the
Dragons looked like 17 years later in
terms of flex special laughter even
dinosaurs from dress mark 1/2 dress park
world yeah like look at them they look
they're not showing you much that's
that's the Dragons vision though it's
kind of gay oh why is it dragon's vision
homosexual I wish to see when I said
why'd I say that because you're a man
why is it and we've been doing arms I
know why relearn it I know we got a
reprogram our brains dude
[Applause]